the quarterings coffee company oh I
can't keep up they're all boring um
they're all they're all so boring bro
quote [__] quartering [__] sitting
there just defending Crowder like him
and Bryson gray have been the most
hilarious
out of all of them Bryson gray who's
Bryson token black there's a few token
blacks he's like the main token black
though okay what what's he saying that
it's a family thing and you should you
should be allowed to uppercut your wife
if you want or whatever yeah I retweeted
him let me read the one that I [__]
wear but it was the old like man it
sounded like he was hitting or nothing I
don't see the big deal blah blah blah
and everybody's like I don't know
screaming at your [__] eight month
pregnant wife with twins that you don't
love her yeah and she won't put medicine
on the dog I don't know that's pretty
abusive I mean it's so funny because
there have been a few people that have
been calling us like simps and being
like wow you guys really just hate
Crowder that much and I'm like dude
we're far from Sims like yeah at one
point somebody was like oh somebody was
like oh so you're like uh believe all
women guy now and I retweeted it I
commented on I go excuse me sir nobody
hates women more than me except maybe
dick Masterson okay and I tagged that
I'm like so I'm a lot look I I can spot
abuse when I see it
[__] my favorite tweet from Bryson
gray was women that don't submit to
their husbands are liberals
wow this is just the [__] gloves on
this just said appalling white death
says the quartering the torturing the
quartering tested negative for
testosterone did you know that oh no
that's bad he doesn't know who you are
by the way no idea no clue
yeah not at all you will
um
do you feel in charge
he deletes quartering deletes more
tweets than a [__] than a bipolar
ex-girlfriend headquartering I get it we
all like to get drunk and throw [__]
malt of cocktails around on Twitter but
you know what every on Friday when I
wake up or be a man leave them up
leave them up
even if you got to apologize or
somewhere even if you gotta correct
yourself later leave it up why you gotta
delete so much stuff oh [__] boy let me
check my notes because he's a [__] yeah
this that's what it says here too so our
notes match okay yeah we have double
blind study that he is a [__] in D-Day
[__]
um and I was good this weekend
speaking of you know who was in Crowder
yeah it was I think I was good this
weekend because I was enjoying it so
much yeah it was just it felt so good it
was like I don't even want to fight with
anybody but it's one of those like
you're sitting there with popcorn going
like I don't need to do nothing no I'm
done I'm literally watching one of one
of my main competitors across the street
their entire Warehouse is engulfed in
flames and I'm like you know what this
is good I'm gonna take a I'm gonna take
the weekend off this is fantastic so
this is uh this is his prouder's and as
you saw can I can I I want to set the
records I don't think people understood
this because I was you know we clipped
the training video that
we found that we acquired that we
acquired and there were some people that
were saying like this is clearly a joke
this isn't real Crowder doesn't really
do this stuff
was it a joke because it was really
specific was it that specifically the
potato microwave part sometimes Steven
likes a potato man what's it was it you
know real quick because we have we
should have a refresher because that was
that was to be fair we really thought
like because people were asking me also
if by the way some people were so
[__] they were literally asking me
if the video was real and I'm like come
on man it's clear like everything in it
I feel like Israel I'm like the stuff in
it feels real but I'm like no it's not
free they don't show that to you in the
[__] office let's just put it to you
I mean how do you say this yeah can we
make can we make a really [__] like if
we ever blow up and we can hire a real
staff no offense Virgie and uh you know
have like a real office building that
everybody comes to can we make a [__]
video like this of course yeah
um wait what was that VHS that Bessie
sent me
oh that was a training thing that was
just snuff porn that he makes on his
free time mm-hmm
yeah it's because it's called red he
causes he they call him the Kabbalah
killer
um and [__] passy that guy's too busy
smoke a weed and not owning a house yeah
Pepsi why are you smoking weed and at
only 15 ounces
Bala killer I thought that's what they
called Madonna's [__] oh no
um remember when Guy Ritchie [__] her
British that's my favorite thing of
Madonna right yeah sure like oh my what
happened to you anyway this is
just real quick in case you miss it
because to be fair this video was was
was so great and when we got it we were
we weren't even doing a Regular Show on
Friday we're doing our movie riff show
which by the way is on locals right now
go check it out but the first 15 minutes
of it was on Rumble so we we were like
we have to play this before the weekend
um so just in case one more time hi
welcome welcome to uh ladder with
Crowder please sit down and watch this
orientation video Dave
welcome to louder with Crowder new
employee Bible
we know you're all excited to get
started so let's run you through your
first day starting with pre-show
walk Stephen's dog
that's great feed Steven's dog
[Music]
make Steven's tea
it's too specific it's it's it's almost
like it's some well important reminder
somebody had first seen the part where I
knew it was real yeah to preheat the mug
and put the cap I'm like no that's in
this part too yeah once yeah tees Brew
put the white cappuccino Cup on top of
the mug again to keep the heat like I'm
like there's no way you nobody wrote
this as a bit you know I mean this was
done to you uh and Mer stopped being too
funny I'm gonna turn on the watch or
[__] watch it like we need a new butt
we need a light a shut up
deliver the tea to the studio about five
minutes before runtime oh I have a
feeling that his wife is going to be
delivering a lot of tea to the studio
important reminder make sure to place
the tea on the right
stuff like that sparkling water on the
left
[Music]
our stock Steven's fridge
you know Marsh if I was crazy if I was
this is me guessing but if I was just
guessing I would think this re feels
like somebody who kept emails
with rules and memos that may have been
passed around and then maybe
transitioning this piece some things
together together to a video Hmm this is
my favorite even once a potato
sometimes I will need a potato
sometimes even needs a potato that's why
you hired Brian Cowan
[Music]
ass part by the way
the pop quiz it's about to come up I've
already in my head have role played what
happened here here's what happened here
by the way what numbers do you press on
in five minutes it's a [__] dial
microwave yeah of course
that's right
[Music]
somebody probably cooked a potato by
mistake at 250 because they saw 2.5 and
he probably sent out a memo saying and
2.5 is 200 cook your own potatoes
you are
[Music]
good job now on to run through
set up Steven's iPad it's just [__]
maniac
[Music]
inverted dark mode
inverted dark mode yeah exactly
[Music]
good job now on to the post show
Queen Steven's iPad my God
[Music]
it's like
who the [__] he thinks he is like this
is who Stephen Crowder has always been
in his head right he's been this
cigar-smoking alpha male who has people
do things for him yeah but in reality is
what he is he's a guy that's allegedly
running from his homosexuality who
nobody likes he's Dennis when he goes
back to high school he thinks he's the
golden God and everybody goes you're
just a [__] weirdo that yells
everybody I actually did that Friday on
nightwave I played the I played the
Dennis Reynolds like meltdown
compilation video every one of them fits
him to it yeah like every single Dennis
meltdown like you said the one from high
school but even the one in the hospital
or the woman's like I will come down on
this Hospital like the hammer of Thor my
rage will gust through these corridors
like the blowing of a thousand wins he
rather than the Blackness was like I am
not [__] playing with you
[__] she just walks away she's
like I'm not gonna whoop this man's ass
today
all right this is Crowder's comeback
after he screamed at his uh there
probably some sort of context about why
he screamed at his pregnant wife to put
on gloves and with dangerous dog
medicine maybe we'll see what it is
fight like hell with your pregnant wife
Stephen Crowder take to I commented on
my ongoing divorce on Tuesday requesting
privacy in the best interest of the
family no you didn't here's what really
happened sorry I'm there's gonna be a
lot of pausing here but here's what
actually happened what actually happened
was you were tipped off that this video
was about to come out because this guy
that was writing the story prior reached
out to you for comment a couple days
before to be like hey I'm running this
do you have a comment and you didn't
give him a [__] comment so you knew
it was coming so what you did was you
did this thing that we call front
lashing where she tried to get ahead of
the game and go I asked for privacy and
my [__] [__] of an ex-wife and then
what you did was because you can't admit
faults because you're such an [__]
even when you tried to front lash what
you did was you you you cut the yellow
wire instead of the green yeah and then
you just blew out and you made it worse
and then you violated your own NDA then
the story dropped and now you're in what
we like to call uh if you don't mind a
pickle you know you're in a real uh for
like The Sandlot style you're in a real
picture this just in it says he picked
the whole bouquet of whoops and daisies
is what it says here oh no oh no Stephen
what happened but also by court order
hey nice chest bro looks good can't even
tell you how to procedure or agreed upon
by Kofi chest to be fair it does look
good it does he's jacked I'll give it to
him he's [__] jacked
probably doesn't take his shirt off
because he has a bunch of zits on it
that's my remember to router for
somebody who's that big no honestly if
you any dude especially somebody like
him right he would be a dude that we
have a shirt popped off all the [__]
time Dennis Reynolds unless you have
some back me bud by all parties look
broken marriages are ugly and in them
people do ugly things oh it's okay then
hey Marsh
[__] watch it myself honestly of
course the big the single biggest
divorce in the last year has been Tom
Brady and Gisele Bundchen
and they wrap that [__] thing up in a
weekend yeah by the end of like two
weekends one was in the [__] Miami
house one was in the Tampa house
[__] their individual models they
were both already banging somebody else
neither one was dishing dirt on the
other one both of them were Jewish which
is true
they're new people that they were dating
uh oh oh they are no for real
I would never made you something okay
I'll grab it plain otherwise however due
to recent misleadingly edited leaks to
the table Miss edited in what
in what way
in what context that's what everyone
always does the selective misleading
edits
whatever all right you could say that um
maybe it's you know you can always go
it's misleading we had good days too but
that's not the point misleading would
imply that he chopped now if it was five
minutes right and that video was chopped
up yes and you could clearly see there
were Snips you'd go all right what is
this what's she saying to him in between
these but that was a clean three and a
half minute cut of you interacting with
your eight-month pregnant wife who had
twins in her and we all knew the context
we all found out the context what's
misleading everyone everyone thinks
you're an [__] right now you're being
too funny
so the shut up Merc side is currently up
shut up and it will be respected
and Merc by the way 10 I won 10 of the
door I want 10 of the door if you're
gonna plug your shows this is [__]
ten percent
I should have stayed with it grooming
guy ah
yeah your Comedy Tour merch it's now
Royce's comedy it's mine now it's royce
royce Lopez presents and the special
experience and the specials I know the
funniest part was Dave Landau went out
got everything ready to film his special
[__] bought cameras bought uh spent
[__] loads of money on it [__] goza
it tells Stephen hey I'm gonna do a
special can you promote it Stephen goes
promote it I'll headline it
and then it became Stephen Crowder
presents
tell me about your comedy show and they
go yeah you can turn that into an
opening for me the oh honestly the only
thing funnier than that like happening
at period is the fact that it happened
to Dave Landau of all people I know
because he again by all accounts is
she's the nice guy who doesn't deserve
any of that every because you know we
know we've been doing this long enough
we know a lot of people that know and
everybody you talk to about him you
always was one of the nicest dudes what
if it's genuinely nice dude always never
heard a bad thing no it's so true then
he's not funny but but
Nick de Paulo though no
yeah I tell you what that's great well
I'll tell you what why don't you come
over my house and [__] my wife too
[__] laundry Steve
that's a good point Marsh I'm also
getting uh 10 of your of your cat
Channel I worked it out that's not even
fair that's nothing to do with the time
yeah that doesn't but the problem is
we're bringing eyeballs over there
aren't we that's by the way that's our
Crowder's argument it really is no it
really is like you're right it's the
equivalent if you started a new new
thing yeah and you had like this side
Channel and I'm like well you know ROTC
is caught out why people know us exactly
I should get a cut you're like your
other like [__] Channel where you're
doing [__] nope sorry reasoning his
reasoning to Dave as to why he owned
Dave Landau special
was because he let him keep the door
yeah
let him he lit he lit keep the door at a
show that he booked
[Laughter]
[__] Christ bro imagine Jesus [__]
Christ bro this guy really is the
[__] worst human we didn't really
focus enough on the Landau stuff too
before the divorce no because the
promise and we were going to play more
of it but did hit this then all the
other stuff hit so fast you know what I
mean Steve
slow down one disaster at a time slow
down we got no goddamn prep some weeks
in the next week we're [__] skipping
all this [__] six hours we have six
hours of content between merch and I all
right give us a [__] break help us
out
I commented on my ongoing divorce on
Tuesday requesting privacy in the best
interest of the family but I called my
wife a stupid [__] and listen if you're
gonna have her like Poisoned With
polonium or something like that wait a
few weeks Jesus let us let it play out
bud Poisonwood polonium sounds like a
bit shoot documentary
court order agreed upon by all parties
look broken marriages are ugly and in
them people do ugly things myself of
course included I would never claim
otherwise however due to recent
misleadingly edited leaks to the Tabloid
press without context and not subject to
consequences of the Court
well if not privacy the next best option
is truth
truth should always be the first option
yeah truth should always be being read
off a teleprompter
that feels feels like truth it feels
like your truth is pre-written by an
Asian attorney
so today I have filed a motion to
officially unseal all files as they
relate to the matter of legal record
finances relevant medical records
including mental health history or
evaluations depositions and any motions
or sanctions from the courts of Texas I
will not be leaking private marital
information to the Press but if the
Privacy Agreements are not respected by
all parties I will address all that is a
matter of irrefutable legal record in
full context next week you're not
getting them back Crowder you could
[__] listen you listen this is the
internet you [__]
that little snippet of a ring camera is
going to matter more than thousands of
pages of deposition because one shows
your character the other one is just
legal Mumble jumbo you think it was just
because of what you were saying in the
video it's here's the thing that because
the people that are defending them it's
not just the [__] ring camera video
it's not just that it's every subsequent
thing that has led up to that moment in
a pattern of [__] Behavior
I hear you Royce but hear me out on this
hmm let them cook
Lobster
but he's that's he's doing it to himself
yeah let him go ahead let him unseal
everything let him burn his whole
[__] Kingdom to the ground this is
great for us you think this is like
you think this is a good thing for you
it's not you already brought the people
to rumble now they're ours when they
leave you yeah that's fine I just have
to get used to the cursing and the
actual comedy
you guys telling me that you think
Stephen Crowder is gonna isn't gonna be
the first human in [__] history that
looks good in a divorce is that what
you're telling me yeah no you're right
boy here's the thing Crowder the first
by the way the first man
yeah look good in a divorce
can I make things even better for you
because I was thinking about this over
the weekend because I've been having so
much fun with this and
the reason Stephen Crowder is having
such a problem overcoming this situation
is because this isn't one of your
typical left and right things where it's
like the left is coming after me and
trying to destroy me respect this
privacy half of the right is also coming
after him and here's why
think about this
Stephen Crowder could have said no to
the Daily wire contract without doing a
special show without recording Jeremy
boring's phone calls without registering
a website a month before he recorded
Jeremy boring called stop VidCon he
could have done all that but instead he
decided to make it content so he made an
enemy and I hate to either wires those
people who hate Tyler wire here don't
get me wrong but he made an enemy of the
daily wire the other half of the
conservative movement so now the people
that little round table that we saw of
all I'm talking about is chest thing
that little Michael malas and and and
[__] um who Shapiro and and and and
uh Candace Owens and all those [__]
people and I don't even know Jeremy
boring all those people would currently
now be circling the wagons to defend you
can is someone's included by the way if
you think Canon is doing it because he
gives a [__] about Hillary Crowd Oh no
she does not she's just a petty black
[__] she does not canis Owens was vert
was metaphorically sucking his dick
the chucking his dick up until the the
crate the uh the uh you got sassy with
her bosses that they said all right the
daily wire thing so then it became of
turf war so now the problem is you you
don't you don't have enough
you don't have enough Social Capital
right You've Lost Your allies no good
will because you got so full of yourself
that you decided to go after the only
people that would have defended you now
say what you want about merch and I
we've always gone off to these people
we're not trying to build fake allies we
know these people [__] hate us and
that's perfectly fine but this little
this little
conservative little group of people we
said at the beginning go watch our old
clips
we said it they're gonna eat each other
alive these people are all hate each
other and now they all hate each other
and now they're all fighting with each
other and I think it's hilarious I I am
I couldn't be happier frankly watching
these people eat each other has been
so much fun for the last couple weeks
it's been it's been the highlight of the
last couple weeks if I would have told
you Marsh a year ago that in this Fiasco
Blaze TV would be the one coming out on
top and laughing would you believe me
because that's what happened they got
Landau for a steal
so now they have another person on their
show
they are not involved in any other's
drama because they never they let
Crowder go see here's the thing it might
have been by mistake but Blaze let
Crowder go right on time because this
could have been Stephen Crowder on the
blaze that's right
that was very recent he left the blaze I
don't think they cut him I still to this
day I think he walked away because he
wasn't getting enough of his peace yeah
I think he wanted to be like 50 50 with
Glenn Beck and Glenn Beck was probably
like get the [__] out of here you know
what I mean that's why I think I think
he left I think he actually flew too
close to the Sun and said [__] you I'll
build my own Empire and then he [__]
over the daily wire people and then this
[__] happened like it's just bro this is
gonna be
it's gonna be weird watching them in the
coming weeks he's going to age poorly
he's gonna start crashing and burning
bro I'm just telling you man this this
has been something to T this has been
something to see and honestly the truth
of the matter is I tuned in this morning
to watch Crowder's show numbers are down
and uh the entire well I'm seeing the
entire 90 of the chat was in people
making fun of him
it was bad it was really really bad
not good buddy
uh yeah it's it's I'm telling you man
that's that's a Tucker Rumble has an
opening oh yeah just saying but you want
to be top dog come over here you'll be
the top dog we just [__] signed uh
Johnny Manziel and now we're having some
problems yeah apparently Ryan Leaf was
and everything was cut out to be yeah
yeah so